I was pissed the whole Drive no gas
money you gotta pull over he's hungry
yeah and then at the end of the night
when you bring back bring me my Rick's
house
you always say bring me my Rick sighs
Ricky he don't he knows we think that so
that's a trick man we're getting home
can I see be you're harshly god damn it
god damn it like that was this was legit
homeless legit lift up here with the
girl she crew him out for a while
so he was just sleep up the school
sleeping it might say been asleep in lab
he was one of those guys like you or see
that gonna hide in the store and go to
sleep in there and he's still with the
same the same woman oh [ __ ]
it's gonna be one of those nights
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
just when you thought it was safe
[ __ ] they nothing gone out on TV
and look who shows up
[Laughter]
is death wish five [ __ ]
break up the botanist and if you're
under 18 go kill yourself
and eight this type of party tonight
[ __ ] we're going deep I don't
want no 18 year olds on here [ __ ]
duplicating beating stars you give me
anxiety already a little [ __ ]
we're going deep into the murky waters
we got Lee's favorite weed with no label
on it
my French cousins smoked this last night
he's missing a night today he's walking
around with an eye patch that's how you
know reef is good we got the stars here
salud weed 12 of them tonight we're
going deep 2,400
well it's Roberto Clemente weekend and
[ __ ] another respect for Puerto Rico and
nobody got edibles down there yes they
do they got no white delicious
nutritious and been vicious only three
carbs burn I'm saying you don't watch
your carbs we got to do what you got to
do boom just like that
it's gonna be that type of party and I'm
happy you're here we're doing a special
Tuesday edition cuz I gotta go to New
York and I got time to [ __ ] around with
you people tomorrow you're understanding
I said to do and people to see look at
poorly over there you know what the
problem is you have another pocket yeah
that's the problem another bonnet we got
a great guest tonight my brother Rick
Ramos is here we got an in-house studio
guest when I gotta tell you her name
she's behind the [ __ ] curtain man she
don't want to come out
she's gonna be the last one to come out
don't worry about nothing but we're here
we'll quit who said bonk it
should we smoke the cheese the
strawberry cheesecake or should we go
for what's behind curtain number two
which is cremation this like Ralphie
Mays - is you understand we'll go in
deep tonight you know you're going deep
when you're smoking Ralphie May sashes
there's 500 pounds of THC and those
[ __ ] things you understand me
people like how many milligrams you
smoke I don't know 500 pounds how's that
beer [ __ ] mama said yeah Papa
said no I mean no you need no no I know
but this is 12
hey 3 that's 12 less of my games one
time before 4 2 times 4 is 8 3 times 4
12 get the [ __ ] multiplication burn
you got three more cups got killers back
here that's it I mean one I'll respect
you for the black cat that got run over
by the car yesterday
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that's another pastor you follow me the
other one the meals got on the way of
New York you watch that show yet on
Netflix but Pablo Escobar's hitman
pehota
it's in Spanish 88 episode I'm gonna
have my wife download 10 episodes for
the flight hold back 20 no some of the
episodes you can't no you can't download
my son's Aniki
you could download Marcos the other one
was a couple shows you can't yeah the
Netflix thought we could download so
would you think a John with from 55
years old five hours a day
I can't walk five minutes he while he
trains five hours with savages Jackie
Chan's been delivering when you were
[ __ ] doing nothing [ __ ] me Jackie
can't invent it the [ __ ] fortune
cookie I do it no you watch some what's
done and I tell you well this is bad to
that other [ __ ] dude that came along
gently he did to the one movie the woman
that was one with alia i watch that yeah
[Music]
that's the good one unleash that's a bad
[ __ ] right I'm gently control
beating on your dog those are some good
[ __ ] movie did you see me and my
daughter watching Chinese connection
last night she was losing her mind last
night
oh you know four and a half it's time
he's a brain
she loses her mind she throws kicks and
[ __ ] but she was like she would watch it
for a minute and like being throw him
and she would catch herself and then go
yeah you like that [ __ ] look at
him kicking ass when you want to Chinese
connection with you for me
does anybody could watch it with your
son [ __ ] try to sell your daughter
Bruce Lee at four-and-a-half when she
just saw the commercial for the Barbie
movie yeah I did it I'm not much of a
Salesman I got to do the one scene that
was critical I knew she's not ready for
it yet I gotta bring her back that's
what you gotta do you gotta [ __ ] just
show it and that's what the [ __ ] you
can't raise your kid with big [ __ ]
shoes on you understand me they'll eat
them up alive in today's society you
gotta raise your kid ready to stab a
[ __ ] because if not they're
gonna shoot at the church your kids by
the time he's eight that's not a [ __ ]
gorilla cross it had a [ __ ] escape I
gotta shoot a gun by her just for the
power of the brick presents' you
remember that's what you did it for so
the [ __ ] gun gun wouldn't scare no we
gotta take a deep I'm gonna get an ak-47
and shoot in the backyard so she can I
tell you prepare your kids [ __ ]
whatever these nerve what's the guy's
name the guy never up the nursery rhymes
yeah dr. Zeus can suck my dick
dr. Zeus is for [ __ ] the 70s you
gotta raise your kids now with dr. Zeus
for the machine gun I saw death I saw
death wishes a young man so I thought
death wish when I came on the movie
theater I saw the valachi papers' first
then I want to see death wishing a movie
to where he had death was come out death
was 70 74 I was 11 again because wish
he blew up he was international at that
place we're eating stars here wait a
second everyone everybody's asking bleep
where's Lee's bonded I know what kind of
[ __ ] host of mine let me flip this
out my nice bonding the good [ __ ] that
he likes oh [ __ ]
there you go little something so
nobody's feelings get hurt we'll do this
little pond the ruining can I get you
something Sam with you sure you not
hungry to eat dinner well gee for dinner
huh no Cod lasagna are you are you a
vegan what kind of me there's no meeting
Oh Sookie lasagna or Jesus Christ did
you make it so PMS is so you're vegan
are half a vegan you're not nothing at
all just clubs with me you like me
I want no misunderstandings insane I
thank you for [ __ ] teriyaki beef you
turn the time are we gonna run yellow
sugar and we'll off
[Music]
there we go we say at the exercises this
is the [ __ ] this the one I juiced riff
favor we right here but you're leaving
I'm doing breathing exercises for the
bomb in wait in front and look at the
spots got run away today beautiful you
should trim your beard yeah you me and a
little [ __ ] up last night you look
like one of those Gary arrows let's do
it you ready times I'm looking this
beautiful beautiful there you go
patience patience there you go there you
go my finger was on fire I'll give a
[ __ ] jack we've run your finger in the
neighbors we for there you go tough for
them deck for the brown sugar let's call
out with those last two stars where they
often what's wrong with this guy I told
you this is record week
[Music]
Tuesday like [ __ ]
how you know it's Tuesday I got nothing
next Tuesday's show at The Comedy Store
is no long I'm in the original room next
Tuesday but by 9:20 I still need you
down there I'm trying to showcase for
Netflix I need your [ __ ] down
there right I need to have a ride at the
[ __ ] store next week the whole thing
metal detectors everything we're going
deep
like when Tupac shot up the [ __ ]
place in 92 before he died this [ __ ]
[ __ ] Tupac [ __ ] Chris D'Elia
didn't know oh yeah two o'clock got shot
man shot somebody with the Comedy Store
the House of Blues back
[Music]
somebody was there we're gonna start
this show we got time to [ __ ] around in
people wait wait here we go here we go
we're gonna come with listen you gotta
have the right music for bondage I'm
saying let's do it oh [ __ ]
[Music]
Gober they go it's a killer for Manila
without the thriller look at that
professional you know why he took uncle
Joey's how to do a bomb hit course in
two easy weeks 1-800 bomb it we're
taking spots for next summer it's gonna
cost you no [ __ ] you don't say
don't worry about none would take a and
there's no financial aid here an ITT
Tech it's locked the doors and saw his
Trump University so your options are
limited you understand me for ITT Tech
if you graduate from ITP tech plus I get
[ __ ] I'm saying hopefully they got
lifetime placement
[Music]
and that's it and that's that what else
you I'm gonna tell you next Tuesday
comedy store 915 original room I need
you for the Netflix showcase all right
New York is so bad I can't help you out
but I'll see you [ __ ] afterward
blowing bong hits on 20th Street we're
gonna get pizza with team del rey's the
whole [ __ ] thing that's it and that's
that flee to Stars don't make me break
out another bad Nastasia I don't want no
problems no problems anyway I love you
[ __ ] youtube.com slash c / Joey
Diaz is the place to be ten minutes
we're going with movies tonight your
favorite ones your worst ones and we're
gonna [ __ ] educate here you little
[ __ ] and if you're under 18 go
watch Disney your [ __ ]
we got nothing for you you stay black
[Music]